hello and welcome to this video playing
bath oh em gee I really play the guys
with no score I have half point out of
four games against this guy amazing yeah
the hoop no variation yeah this is a
it's a rare line I think b6 I think b6
was what I had against this okay so he
wants to go E 4 I guess what does he do
he against this not I don't remember I
simply don't remember
yeah white intention here are very
aggressive tries to build a black center
and start an attack yeah this is
interesting if five yeah you have to do
it probably anyway so let's go with you
five can if evil looks like the move to
play it to be active efore takes on 666
on d3 is e 4 and Bishop f4 later but
okay after this it's a tempo first he
has to I guess cover c4 and a hand and a
half eform I still have this move okay I
can still play this takes Queen takes
rook e8 unclear very unclear
consequences if I go Queen g5 they might
take it and play of six but okay I can
take C for them
well well didn't see that one coming
I hope I'm not blundering this in a
couple of moose Ian's as possible
okay so mm-hmm what is it what is the
what did ya jee for once to bring the
bishop around Wow
okay which is free while we place is
very well
Wow
try to bring it around 28 but not in
true Wow I'm kind of stunned what
happens here it's not even clear that
I'm threatening to take down 26 now
probably I am
sorry to have to do anything I mean I
can just sit and wait it seems that i'm
not getting checkmated quickly at least
it would still be kind of interesting
can i maybe there are so stuff against
the sea for porn if I can I need to
bring the Queen around two to a light
square to somewhere around here g8 f7
and so on
oh come on how can you play like this
how can you do this to me he's really
playing excellently here
he has fruit g6 always against this
stuff it doesn't i cannot bring the
Queen around I would like to bring the
Queen to the to the Queen side maybe now
when he shoots 4g for the seco 4g for
yep time morning
so what to do now taking it to on well
g6 I'll take just six and now this
covering the light square sir it doesn't
want to take it I understand
I can do this and now now try to take
stuff I can't just queen my goodness
wait for it oh wow wow wow that was very
tough I was definitely deep in a very
bad position at one point I'm pretty
sure he played this really really well
somehow somehow it helped though it's
somehow health yeah and came this is
some check really really tough to play I
can't so what does the computer want to
do Knight a5
yeah this is probably okay yeah yeah it
is okay once you see it relate i mean i
really had some doubts there with this
with this idea so this is why i went
where I went if five yeah now this is
the key moment he force it's the obvious
move maybe I have to play it I thought
that I might I thought that this might
not be so great this Oh Noah this is the
move that I didn't see I didn't see you
know I thought I'll go let's say rook c8
and he goes into form and I take and he
goes here and I thought that this
wouldn't be good because I cannot
intensifier pressure against the form
and this is also week and sometimes this
queen is the problem it cannot easily
move because of f6 and some cases this
is what I saw but I have this move which
is very strong very nice and now I'm
threatening so he has to take with the
Queen and now the engine just plays this
move to grab this next and play against
all the week squares that's pretty nice
and this is for example now directly
leading into problems so this is the
thing if I go e4 I'm fine if he takes by
the way I play 95 and this is a nice
position yeah here i'm getting the porn
back and i'm just in good shape okay so
i didn't do that and now he got this
this initiative again the engine wants
to go E for this time based on this idea
Wow but what about this kind of thing
I had this wins so this wins but this is
winning the black yeah okay okay I'm so
Queen g5 24 and now I had to defend yeah
its luggage really dangerous let's see
off the computer if the computer fine
sir finds a position where i was losing
or close to it it doesn't seem to be and
it always gives white 0.4 you know
direct them break through anything so I
defended reasonably reasonably well wait
here could have taken on h5 oops oops
okay yeah this is I think probably not
that brilliant opening this but okay it
was still very difficult in a practical
game ok so here I should be winning yeah
I was I tried I directly went for this
returning the the exchange and here the
the engine just gives me a flat win yeah
that's problem that's very likely as c4
is dropping ok it approves of my plane
it just wants to do something else here
and wants to go f5 switching over to the
Kings idea that makes an awful lot of
sense
hmm excellent it's better better than my
and my play here yeah here it gets gets
a time scramble so here Queen f1 was
winning yeah this was my original
intention but then I saw this I thought
ooh attention but I can just go here and
nothing happens and now Black is doing
that tag I can yeah he it shifts back to
white and that in that time scramble
that can be that you can't a group which
is seven yeah okay we both had
absolutely nothing on the clock okay
this is a new all-time high thanks for
watching